the ingredients to create a tactical
game a solid cover system so the cover
system Ghost Recon phantoms is very
distinctive it's very unlike the cover
system in other games and I love other
shooters have them but I was is quite
unique in the behavior and the way you
use it for so improving your accuracy
and aiming it slows down the game play
it makes players be more cautious with
advancing forward it is extremely
flexible I think the illustrators with a
bit of a prop so for example in most
games your cover system is kind of like
you just pick out that's all you do but
for us you allowed to pick all the way
around so you can even pick over and you
kind of sweep the area under it so one
of the beauties of the cover system is
that it actually reduces a recoil
actually increases your accuracy and
it's critical to this being if you do
not use cover you will die so one thing
that we really wanted to achieve with
Ghost Recon phantoms a sense that the
users would naturally come together and
play as a team team plays essential in
Ghost Recon phantoms because you have
three different character classes
everyone that has its strengths and
weaknesses they're all battling to try
and capture a point against an enemy
team which is also balanced of these
three caps classes team play that the
core of cosmic on phantom experience and
the recipie that you need to test and
tweak every day and the need for
playtest on a daily basis so playtests
happen every single day either level
design specific or generally speaking
changes to gameplay changes to some of
the systems changing to the user
experience the play testers help us to
get feedback on weapons so they help us
figure out if certain guns are too
powerful for example devs will be
basically running the game they'll be
giving opinions and then they'll come
back to me and say okay so this is what
the guns are they feel a bit
underpowered this particular weapon just
doesn't feel right the recourse to hyper
hats and after we collect all this
experience we just have an analysis and
beyond
we go okay I think we know what to do
and then we'll try it again until such
time that everyone is satisfied and we
go ok perhaps the players get a shot at
it now we don't push something out if
you don't feel it makes sense in our
game the plate s feedback cos that's
strong enough that it's not right and we
will adapt it til we feel that we reach
your sweet spot where it's something
that makes sense for us as a business
and make sense for users is something
that they can joy as well ah my favorite
gun in the game I would say it's a
nemesis its a 50 caliber sniper rifle it
pops hits in a single shot and it's a
really slow gun and just by the sound of
it okay this guy killed him with this
damn Isis rifle and and you know he
raged so he knows we're just listening
and dying to this sound of this gun this
player has bought this gun it was
actually a real challenge creating this
gun because it's like need to have a
balance of the super high damage at the
same time you don't really want to
experience with you should play in the
body and the player dies immediately so
it's kind of a delicate balance between
the two we're always creating against
with a clear intention in terms of
design that's very often the community
and the way they're playing the game is
quite different and that's what's so
interesting with the players in the
community they always surprise us and
when I just comes in it's all about
that will design invisible to the player